georgia's governor says he cannot obey
president trump's demand
to call the legislature into session to
reverse the state's presidential vote
governor brian kemp says that would be
illegal
the president complained bitterly about
george's vote count at a weekend rally
the state's two republican senators who
now face runoffs
mark straussman is in marietta georgia
near atlanta with more on this story
mark there was an empty podium
the other day or last night rather
because one of those senators
skipped a debate good morning yeah it's
uh
good morning to you gail uh republican
incumbent david perdue skipped the
debate he would tell you that he's
already debated
democrat john ossoff once and so now
he's just talking directly to georgia
voters
ossoff would tell you that purdue
skipped it because he got clobbered the
first time
georgia voters will decide now with
these runoff elections less than a month
away
i have built my career republican
senator kelly lefler keeps her campaign
message
simple she backs president trump all the
way and sidestepped when asked if the
president
won reelection president trump has every
right to use
every legal recourse available in our
own state we've seen
time and again that we have
investigations that need to be completed
she called her opponent reverend rafael
warnock a radical liberal
he described her as out of touch with
georgia voters
after being in the senate for 10 months
she does not have a case to be paid for
why the people of georgia
should keep her there but at least they
debated on the same stage
in georgia's other runoff democratic
challenger john ossoff faced an
empty podium incumbent republican
senator david perdue
was a no-show it shows an astonishing
arrogance
and sense of entitlement for georgia's
senior u.s senator
to believe he shouldn't have to debate
at a moment like this in our history
the president campaigned for both
candidates saturday night in georgia
but spent most of his hour and a half
long speech complaining about his own
election results
the candidates themselves spent less
than three minutes on stage with the
president
you must go vote and vote early he
pushed supporters to vote
while casting doubt on the election
process by repeating
false claims he was cheated out of a
victory
we'll still win it and they're going to
try and rig this election too
his refusal to concede has sparked a
republican battle in georgia
he has pressured governor brian kemp to
call the state's legislature into
special session
to overturn joe biden's victory here
kemp refused again in a statement sunday
night saying
that is not an option allowed under
state or
federal law you got to make sure your
governor gets a lot tougher than he's
been he's got to get a lot tougher
the president has also been tough on
georgia's republican secretary of state
brad raffensberger says there was no
evidence of fraud
in georgia right now we don't see
anything that would overturn you know
the will of the people here in georgia
but many top republicans here are also
worried at the way the
president is trying to undermine the
integrity of georgia's elections
and here's why tony they're worried that
republican voters might be discouraged
from showing up
at next month's runoff i'll take it mark
thank you